I paid Chris Orzechowsky thousands of
dollars to be my business coach and one
of the smartest things that he told me
that changed my business forever is
actually from Kanye West and where he
says there's a thousand of them but only
one of you. This applies to clients,
customers, everything. There's a
thousand clients out there. There's a
thousand customers out there but there
is only one of you with your unique
skill set, your unique background, your
unique personality, things that make
doing business with you significantly
more pleasurable than someone else. And
when you instill this in your mind, you
move from needing those people to having
this in non-neediness or a presence
about your business that makes you
significantly more attractive to
everyone around you. So the next time
you lose a deal or a customer cancels or
anything like that and you're looking
down at yourself, just remember there's
a thousand of them but only one of you.